one more example because these are a bit
boring really you just see a once but
you can see a lots of times and you can
do different things to it for example
let's do we've done we've done index
notation in very very basic 4 if I
showed you this here you go another
expression it's a lot more complicated
we're doing lots more things to it ok
but I can take any value of a and I can
substitute it in exactly the same way
okay let's take me same to you guys 3
negative 2 okay so when a equals 3 right
everywhere I see a I'll swap it out I'll
substitute it I'll replace it which ever
would you like ok so the expression you
cause ok let's do it
I could see in 3 places 1 2 3 ok so I've
got 3 squared minus 3 times 3 plus 3 on
2 plus 1 there you go that's my
expression and I've switched out all of
my age for threes okay let's quickly
evaluate it 3 squared 9 just by
coincidence this is going to be 9 as
well isn't it 3 over 2 I suppose we
could write that as a mixed numeral
that'll be one half good you've got that
one hanging around over on the end these
tonight they're just gonna cancel each
other aren't they
so these disappear one half plus one is
excellent there you go
that's your heart this is last one down
here excuse me
when a equals negative two okay what am
I going to get
I'll have everywhere I see the a I'm
gonna put it negative two so be careful
brackets will really help here I'll show
you why see how there's an alien I'm
gonna give two in like so just as a word
of caution right this is totally
different to this see they're different
what's being squared
in each case here the negative two is
being squared the whole thing that's big
squared here just the two this would be
negative form and that's not all we get
again over here in a second okay good
what I got left minus 3 negative 2 again
I've got another sweet I'll put a bigger
top and a plus one okay how you hear me
did you up question yeah what did the
breakfast do I guess what they do is
they make sure any operation you do like
squaring or multiplying or dividing or
that kind of thing it happens to the
whole number whereas here that square
it's just happening to the two not the
not the whole number not the negative as
well right which would be something
different okay so now I've done all of
the substitution let's quickly evaluate
it negative 2 times negative 2 what
happens to the negatives they can't
shoot angers make a positive so you get
4 okay I've got to date leaves again
don't I
I've got a negative here and negative
here so I should get plus 3 times 2
which is 6
all right what happens over here
negative 2 divided by 2 negative divided
by a positive that's gonna be a negative
negative 1 in fact plus 1 will be it
okay these two guys cancel I just get 10
that makes sense I can't so let's just
summarize substitute is that all of
these things right taking where you see
a per new rule and just checking out
what happens if you put a particular
value that it could be anything
the value can be positive or it can be
negative or if we wanted to actually I'd
like you to try this now you can put in
a fraction as well you can put in any
kind of number right every way you see
that printable you replace it we switch
it you swap it you put in a table and
then you can evaluate it again the end
okay sure
should we do it together do you want to
do a quiz ha see what happens I'll do it
quickly so the people who say no can
have it ever done with in a quick matter
time the people who want it will have
their curiosity satisfied okay April's
aha I'll do it in red since I read over
there this is the expression I've got
okay so everywhere I see a I'm gonna
stick in a half right watch first a half
swim again I put the brackets to make
sure I square the whole thing okay minus
3 plus 1/2 over 2 plus 1 okay now like I
said before with the negative the
brackets are really helpful here's an
example why have a look at that fraction
man if I didn't write in those brackets
if I wrote down that hmm is it a 1/2
divided by 2 or is it 1/2 Emma - because
those are different right
so that's why like which one is it well
you better write brackets so you can
tell which one it is okay now let's go
through one at a time huh squid what
does that actually mean that's a lot of
times I hop in
I'm going to write that out before I
write the answer 1/2 times 1/2
there you go there's 1/2 squared minus 3
times 1/2 we could do that can't we
what's that 3 times 1 is just 3
ok ok so far so good everything down ok
now we get to this guy a half now
do you agree if I gave you like this 10
over 5 something like that but what is 2
in fun
that's two isn't it the reason why is
because it's the same as saying this the
fractured symbol that line really is the
same as divisions just with right a
different way cuz sometimes convenient
so therefore this really is 1/2 / - is
it tip 1/2 divided by 2 said ok all
right so I'm leaving it plus 1 okay so I
thought some work yeah now I do multiply
fractions how do I multiply fractions
yeah it doesn't
well that's division isn't it we are
going to do that a second
or you have to cure fractions with the
multiply I don't have to take do I what
we're gonna do yeah that's right so I do
1 times 1 which is 1 and then I made 2
times 2 which is 4 ok so that's that's
just a corner that's 1/2 squared minus 3
over 2
okay a house divided - now we can do the
upside down business right that's 1/2 if
I turn that into multiplication what do
I have to do to - I could turn it upside
down it's really to everyone isn't it so
it's actually 1/2 do that division to
multiplication this - doing what it's
called when you flip it upside down
because of special because that's what's
wrong
the reciprocal that's exactly right half
their circle plus 1 ok we're getting
that that's a quarter still that's a
quarter as well is it all right that
over here by the way why can I knew that
over do you remember why it has a
special day all these things with a
couple of a couple of lessons ago it's
one of the laws we learnt three of them
tell you can do an addition in any order
ok so I can move over here quad plus 1/4
minus 3 over 2 plus 1 we're almost there
if I've got a quarter here and a quarter
there you put it together I get half
plus one promise it off - 3 / - what's
different - is a a mix different it's
one and a half isn't it right
maybe if I add this 180 here that's one
in a half isn't it - one and a half huh
all that work and look at zero at the
end I feel the dog I want my money back
now that was long partly because I'm
fractions are harder to work with but we
can still work with it they followed the
same rules you can take a valium in know
you and you can substitute it into an
expression and you'll get another value
at the end